uh you mentioned having 49 albums I
always say this uh when we talk about
just consistency as a MC as a rapper as
a artist I feel like you're one of the
most consistent guys in the game you've
always been
extremely I mean no matter what was
going on in your life you you always
have the time to you know hone in and
create and make an album more collab
with an artist to make a project um for
you uh like you know obviously it's a
passion thing but like for whatever
reason do it still bother you that maybe
you don't get the acknowledgement or the
accolades or the flowers as as a rapper
that you do for all the other [__] n
because I knew if I put 100% energy
behind music it' probably be a lot
bigger right and I argue with my DJ you
know Teflon and this two are about
changing our setup and trying new things
and I just told him I said bro it's a
bandwidth issue at this point like I'm
running cookies clothing I'm running
cookies a weed business I'm running
Vibes papers I'm running you know this
compound and our media you know out
company that we're trying to build and I
only have so much time for music I told
them music is my therapy bro like I
don't really look at it like it's my
business if I treat it more like a
business I probably make way more money
I probably get way more respect I've had
people like two chains like bro like why
don't you be like
our like Mexican version of rck bro I
was like you got that talk you got that
respect like people [__] with you but
you're not putting enough respect on
like your image and the way I'm like bro
I'm just a real dude bro I don't really
be tripping off like really trying to
build myself as this big old as a facade
if you like you're not a character no I
just feel like music is a good it's a
good therapy for me it's a challenge for
me to still try to stay relevant after
all this time it's a it's a way for me
like to be creative outside of like all
this other stuff I have fun doing it but
I don't treat like my number one
priority I feel like if I did I could be
like a French Montana or something like
that right like I could be looked at as
like a bigger artist right I could wear
jewelry every day and glasses and be
fitted up but like I'm comfortable in
this sweatshit right now I'm rich as
[__] I don't need to show it
right like for what like my new flex is
not the flex I got a pair of earrings on
but I'm not wearing my you know 20
different rings I'm not wearing big old
chains or I'm not really worried about
my outfit so much I don't give a [__]
all the billionaires I meet look like
[__] bumps they pull up looking real
humble and some dressed down ass [__]
and that's how that's what I want to be
like at this point like bro if you seen
the whip I'm driving in right now I gave
the mayback truck back I'm like bro [__]
all this flashy [__] I got it there's
the world knows I got it so why why even
try to prove it anymore no I feel you
I'm on that same [__] when I mean
obviously I'm much lower lower lower
level but like yeah I'm I'm not uh you
know I have I own a nightclub now and
Scott still you you were there but my
partners man they love the Beamers and
they get they like talk that's just oh I
feel like that's just you're just
rubbing that [__] in people's fa I don't
care my wife has a nice whip I drive my
car uh that I that I don't mind driving
to the bay and putting miles on and you
know my wife is sitting nice and I'm
chill I feel like I feel like right now
we' learned a lot like rest in peace to
P&B bro like I'm rest in peace to all
these other situation all these other
people that are losing their lives but
like I feel like right now the world's
in the most [__] up position we've
seen it in in our generation besides
2008 people are broke people are hurting
it feels it does feel though the energy
is not the same in terms of like the
literal loss that's happening in 08 but
it feels almost like like you could feel
it the amount of calls I get every day
for people trying to get money or trying
to figure out ways to make money or
people feeling the loss of like emotion
is crazy and so I don't want to be the
one to be rubbing no [__] in people's
faces right now I rather just stay
lowkey do my thing but as far as music
goes I'm going to keep trying like I'm
going to keep doing my thing having fun
with it I know me and ogz are locked in
for next month and knock out a EP which
would be dope bring some good young
energy around yeah for sure yeah You'
let him use the bus before yeah that's
my little bro right and and I think he's
super dope and I'm like let me get next
to OG and just kind of soak up some of
that energy real quick I already got the
Beats picked out yeah you know Rory
called me the other day he's like bro
like do we need someone to pick be I'm
like bro bro I got you are a great you
are if there's one thing you do well you
pick [__] beats bro man for me in no
jezy project I got some [__] you are
great you You're great an anr yeah
that's why I told Roy yesterday I said
bro I don't like to say this too often
but I I got us that record you dropped
one of my favorite records you dropped
recently it was you uh Conway Jada who
wasse was on that record it was me
Conway Mazy Mazy uh um Styles P no it
wasn't J it was Styles in Styles P and
that [__] was crazy yeah that [__] was
hard but I got the me and ogz project
lined up I got uh me and Larry J want to
do another one but I want I told him I
want to take the time and have all live
music being played so we could perform
that [__] with a band oh that would be
hard me and Mazy got another one coming
I already individuals too yeah I already
got the Beats picked me and be got a
full album already done produced by
Scott Storage I just need to find the
time to like add like two more hooks
maybe like three features well you would
be real haven't done anything for a
while I mean at least officially it's
what it's been like 6 seven years no
what was it prohibition four or three no
Los Meadows was the last one that was
great album just happened during Co and
we got 49 you know keep up man and we
got discouraged because the album was so
good but then for Co we just got [__]
on the promo for it but yeah man I got
me o Jeezy I got me and Mazy got me and
Larry June I got me and be real I'm
going bring one back with my brother
aino you know for old school purposes
just old school mob sound but I'm going
all group projects right now for W I
feel like I've done a good amount of
solos I'm just like let me just go group
projects and just bring different
energies out um have you had the
opportunity to tap in or meet or at
least check out Mexican OT yeah I I mean
I was supposed to be involved in this
project something fell to the cracks but
I got a call about like you know
potentially helping a anr his project um
and like sitting with him and helping
pick beast and come up with just like
features and things like that cuz
someone else recognized Johnny shes
recognized a talent for the year but
something got lost to communication but
he's a VI man he's a good kid I still
want the opportunity though because I
feel like he's a dope ass artist he has
a lot of potential he's blown the [__]
up and I feel like you know [__] if I
just sat with him for one album fck I
bring out some [__] he don't even know
he got yet and I feel like he's got a
good sound he's got a good look he's got
like good momentum but [__] OT I know
the first project things slipped through
the cracks I'm running a billion dollar
business it wasn't on purpose if you
hear it
sit down with me for one project bro I
promise I bring a whole different world
out for you brother just on some just
whole different vibe with the production
with the features with the roll out like
and you know I think that kid's got a
lot of potential